so then why are you talking why should
that matter maybe it's time you stopped
asking questions and started having meet
you in one spot
[Music]
what was that all about
hello internet welcome to film
theory the show that unlike rick and
morty doesn't take a break for
thanksgiving week
luckily though with that one week hiatus
for turkey day behind us
this week finally brought us another
rick and morty episode to gobble up and
let's just say it's uh not one to watch
with the kids
definitely not one to watch with your
parents either maybe you yourself
want to take a long shower after
watching this one i just want to be
clean i
i feel dirty after everything that's
happened it was a weird
episode full of in my opinion wasted
potential
no offense creators of rick and morty
but i gotta be honest with you because i
love you
i mean you put rick in a situation where
his science is rendered useless
it's like the first time ever that we
really see him helpless
but then one commercial break later he's
basically being unstoppable again
that would have been so cool to explore
as a concept if i'm being honest here
was one of my least favorite episodes of
all time
or at least the a plot of the episode
was luckily for me
and luckily for the monetization of this
video this episode actually gave us
something a bit more interesting and a
lot more brand safe to talk about so
forget about that talking mythical beast
i'm far more interested in this
talking regular animal i'm a talking cat
but who cares why is my point
this episode's bee story focuses on the
escapades of jerry
and his newly found talking cat friend
nameless season one gave us talking dogs
but step aside snowball
now we got ourselves a talking cat
voiced by my boy
matthew broderick doesn't know he's my
boy but
love him because he's a theater nerd
like i am and us theater nerds gotta
stick together even though
one isn't aware that the other one
exists sure matthew's a talking cat and
no we're not supposed to ask any
questions about that which
ironically enough is all we're gonna be
doing in today's episode about this new
character in this episode so anyway
jerry
after finding his verbose feline friend
but receiving zero
answers as to what's really going on
decides he's okay enough to take a trip
to florida on the cat's request
okay but why florida because they don't
ask questions they play volleyball they
party and they have fun
right things get considerably less fun
for jerry when the cat decides to use
the beach as a litter box and chooses to
blame it on uh
his human companion poopy in the sand
and buried it with like
two little kicks and just love to hear
like a landmine
it was him things also get considerably
less fun for our talking cat friend when
he stops taking his own advice
and breaks the number one rule of
florida asking too many
questions it's like fight club for
retirees
i'm asking too many questions aren't
they
how ironic we're out of florida you're
overthinking
after a long day together jerry and the
cat's journey comes to an end when jerry
is joined by rick
and the two of them decide that it's
time to get some answers
or specifically one answer why does this
cat
talk the cat's unwilling to spill the
beans so rick pulls out his mind scanner
mind scan
look you're overthinking it the point of
a talking cat is to have fun
and what they see apparently defies
words let's see the truth
what ends up
whatever it is that they see in that
cat's mind scan is enough for jerry to
lose his lunch
and his breakfast probably yesterday's
dinner
we can't see what they're seeing but one
thing's
clear that cat's gotta go get out get
out
both of them seem deeply disturbed by
what they see
but luckily rick has a solution for that
remember the season three episode mortys
mind blowers that showed us how rick has
a way of wiping out memories that are
too traumatizing or disturbing to deal
with well rick remembers
jerry isn't quite sure that he wants to
take the easy way out though no
i don't think we should forget not this
someone has to remember someone will
and with that rick wipes jerry's memory
but not his own and the two of them head
back home but what a weird plot
right i mean out of nowhere there's just
this random talking cat
and then a trip to florida and then when
we see the secondhand reactions of the
people who actually learn the truth of
what's really going on here
it's like the most horrific thing
possible
so terrifying that it even rattles the
unflappable rick sanchez who has
literally seen it all so of course on
this channel we're gonna ask the
question
what did they see what were they looking
at what
is really going on with that darn cast
look you're overthinking it the point of
a talking cat is to have fun
the answer well let's look at the
evidence it might be tempting to assume
that the cat was responsible for
some kind of unspeakably horrifying act
something so
wretched and evil that rick and jerry
just couldn't help but be repulsed by
how evil it was
but it seems unlikely that that's the
case after all rick and jerry's reaction
is to tell the cat to go away get out
get out rick has no ethical qualms about
killing people who deserve it
and sometimes even those who don't
deserve it so if the cat were really
responsible for some kind of
horrifyingly evil act
it seems pretty safe to say that he
would have just killed it right on the
spot
or at the very least made some attempt
to contain it
or cat tain it
he does after all have a prison in a
secret lab under the garage as we saw in
the season 2 episode where he was
keeping blim blam
the baby eating murderer chained up i'm
a murderer that eats
babies and i came to this planet to eat
babies rick and jerry's willingness to
let the cat go indicates that it merely
bore
witness to some kind of evil act or
maybe it just perpetrated an act that
well not evil per se
was so horrifying and disgusting that it
offended their human sensibility this
cat
might not be a threat to their physical
safety but seeing him around would be a
constant reminder
of the terrors that nearly drove them to
the brink of madness
so the kitty has got to go so what then
could have disgusted them so much
the key word here is disgust because
it's one of the most intense emotional
responses that humans can have to a
given stimulus if you drill into the
psychology and evolutionary background
of disgust there's actually a really
good reason for this
disgust is meant to serve as a violent
physical rejection when your body senses
something that could be
a potential contagion it's what
psychology professor
david pizarro at cornell university
describes as a quote
built-in poison detector you can even
see it on infants
you put a few drops of a bitter
substance on their tongue and their
tongue
immediately shoots out of their mouth as
their body reflexively tries to reject
the bitter substance that you're trying
to feed them when we eat expired food
our body wants to throw up so as to
remove the potentially spoiled
or contaminated food from our system and
simply smelling touching or seeing
something that disgusts
us can trigger that same physical
response just like we see
happen to jerry
some things that david pizarro notes as
things that universally elicit disgust
in humans are
poop vomit blood rotting or decaying
flesh
and what all those things have in common
well they're all common ways
that disease spreads so it makes sense
that it would be evolutionarily
advantageous for our bodies
to violently reject or be disgusted by
those things
however david pizarro notes that the
list of universal elicitors of disgust
include not just
those substances but also a lot of
sexual acts
which again makes sense considering that
this is just another way for many
diseases to spread
and would also explain part of why so
many cultures around the world have
taboos around the dirty deed
so that might be on the table as a
possible explanation for why rick and
jerry had a violent reaction to what
they saw in the cat's mind
some kind of ridiculously deviant sexual
act that could be the kind of thing that
would get them
to have this intense sense of revulsion
while also
clearly being okay enough that it isn't
worth an immediate death sentence at the
hands of rick that said
this was an episode where a dragon soul
bonds with a grandfather and his two
grandkids so
it's definitely on theme with the
episode and it would have to be pretty
darn freaky to offend rick but again
this cat was totally down to soul bond
with that same dragon in the
post-credits scene
so it's very clear that there's plenty
of things that are on the table for this
little tabby this
isn't the first time in the series that
jerry's had an intense disgust reaction
to certain bedroom activities either
he had a negative reaction albeit not
quite as strongly
way back in the season one episode
anatomy park
jerry's parents come to visit the family
for the holidays and jerry's none too
happy to find out that they brought
along his mother's new
friend jacob i watch them sometimes from
a chair and sometimes
from a closet almost always dressed as
superman
even though both of jerry's parents seem
very happy and content with the
arrangement
jerry doesn't like it one bit this might
seem like a random thing to bring up
here but
jerry's parents may actually be
important to uncovering the mystery of
what this cat's up to
in the aftermath of the traumatic memory
viewing jerry
says this he was in my home where i keep
photos of my parents not he was in my
home where my wife and kids are
but in my home where i keep photos of
my parents which seems to point to
something involving parents
or older adults something that he would
be ashamed
that his parents learned about so could
that relate to the time that he and the
cats spent together
in florida other online theorists have
also pointed to the fact that the last
time that we saw cats interacting with
the elderly on rick and morty
it was on interdimensional cable with
the dead cat lady parody of weakness
bernie's that had a bunch of cats
puppeteering a long dead woman mrs
sullivan i uh please forgive me for
being forward
but your eyes are so beautiful
certainly gross it's also worth noting
that it was directed
and written by jerry from another
universe written and directed by
jerry smith so it's possible that that
universe's jerry
was inspired consciously or by the
remnants of a long erased memory
by a certain trip to florida with a
particularly energetic and
excitable cat but you know what maybe
we're barking up the wrong tree
or whatever the cat equivalent of that
is like scratching on the wrong post
anyway
there's something a lot more interesting
going on here and that
is the whole meta nature as to what this
cat is trying to say to us as the
audience
the cat's backstory isn't what matters
here
and that's kind of the point that the
writers are trying to tell us
what the cat is doing in this episode is
calling
us out and by us i don't mean the
general viewership of rick and morty
i'm saying us the theorists watching
in the audience here i am standing in
front of camera right now doing a whole
episode dedicated to
whoa there was a cat that could talk in
this show he has some sort of secret
messed up backstory what could it be
when in fact the cats already told us
that maybe we're just better off
accepting the fact that there was a
talking cat in one episode
instead of ruining the fun with all
these questions
in our constant search for answers maybe
it's time you stopped asking questions
and started having fun
i mean it's just a cartoon bro you're
not meant to overanalyze every little
thing
even though that is kind of the concept
of these channels as they exist on
youtube can you tell i feel personally
attacked from this episode
luckily i'm in good company though i
don't have to be the one to yell
this cat for condescendingly lecturing
me about how i should
or shouldn't be enjoying something
because rick sanchez is here to do it
for me find the insinuation that i can't
ask questions
and have fun condescending you see the
cat sets up this dichotomy of
people who ask questions about why
things are the way they are
and people who just like to have fun and
enjoy things without asking questions
but as rick points out
this is a false dichotomy it's possible
to ask questions
and have fun and enjoy things that's why
i
exist here on youtube it is just fun to
look at these sorts of little mini
mystery
so who is right here the cat who says we
shouldn't ask too many questions and
just relax and enjoy ourselves
or rick who insists on finding the
answers
to those questions well let's start by
picking apart the cat's perspective
the plot of this episode reveals that
not even the cat himself
fully subscribes to his just take it
easy man philosophy
sure he claims that he doesn't like
people asking him why he can talk
and he wants to travel to the mythical
land of florida where they never ask
questions
but once he finally gets his wish in
florida he enjoys it
just for a brief amount of time before
he finally starts getting a little antsy
that's great
not being asked why i can talk i'm a
talking cat
but who cares why isn't my point well
nice talking to you
for no reason very next scene the cat
himself is the one who starts asking
questions
that ruin everyone else's fun and he
gets himself
chased out of florida because of it i'm
asking too many questions
aren't they how ironic we're out of
florida
the cat doesn't want people to ask
questions yet in the end
he acknowledges that asking questions is
a natural response to being confronted
with incomplete information
that we as humans or as talking cats
naturally crave answers if we're going
with this meta interpretation and
assuming that the cat's message here
is the show's way of telling fans not to
overthink the show they're watching
well it all feels a bit reminiscent of a
comment by the creators of westworld
back in 2017
after that first season had aired which
acknowledged this sort of tension
between questioning fans looking for
answers
and the creators themselves to quote
jonathan nolan one of the creators of
that show
who yes happens to be the brother of
christopher nolan
quote it's annoying sometimes when
people guess the twists and then blog
about it
but the engagement is gratifying on one
level because if someone guesses your
twist
it means you've done an adequate job of
structuring the series
you can't complain when people are that
engaged it's very gratifying
but stop doing it please and that is the
reason i stopped watching westworld such
a bummer i hate that quote it makes me
so
sad to see that on one hand to stop
doing it please
sounds like the plea that the cat is
making in this episode stop
asking so many questions and just enjoy
the show
but even as he says this jonathan
acknowledges that it's a good thing when
people are talking about your show
online
and that it's gratifying to see that
sort of conversation happening
it's the cat's dichotomy so does that
mean that rick
and by proxy are theorists are right
after all
well not exactly there either just as
the cat wished for a world with no
questions and wasn't happy when florida
delivered exactly what he wished for
rick wished for answers to the question
of how the cat could talk
and he too wasn't happy when he got what
he wished for either
[Music]
looking at how we consume media
sometimes we as fans ask shows to give
us answers to our questions
and we end up ultimately being
unsatisfied with the answers that we get
after star wars the force awakens we
spent two years
speculating about who rey's parents
could possibly be and then found
ourselves disappointed when the last
jedi finally gave us an answer
that they were nobodies in fact we did a
whole episode on this channel at the
time about
how constant theorizing about star wars
led fans to create
expectations for themselves about this
movie that no one could have possibly
delivered on
setting us up for an inevitable
disappointment that being said we could
have been less disappointed if you know
they had actually adhered to check all
this gun
and all which is also a part of that
whole episode just saying it wasn't all
our fault now the last jedi may have
been disappointing for other reasons
and it set up the question of rey's
parents as the kind of thing that would
be answered before the end of the series
so
they couldn't just leave us in the dark
forever but not all
origin stories need to be spelled out
explicitly for us
especially if they're not some big plot
point like the star wars sequels attempt
to do
case in point the star wars prequels
was anyone really dying to find out what
anakin was like as a nine-year-old boy
would anyone watching have been
disappointed if they just you know
left that question unanswered and just
started the prequel trilogy with anakin
as a teenager
like we did with luke in the original
trilogy it's the same thing with solo a
star wars story
no one really cared about han's early
days he was just a cool character we
didn't need him overly explained
some questions are better left
unanswered
exactly because no answer would be
satisfying this episode provides a
perfect example
as much as we might like to theorize
about what the mind scanner saw in the
cat's mind
the fact that the episode didn't tell us
exactly what the scanner saw
made things far more interesting it
sends our imaginations
spinning into directions that are far
more entertaining than a single answer
could ever be it's like that classic
horror movie problem
the monster you can't see is always
going to be scarier than the monster
that you can see
because the limits of your imagination
are beyond what a practical effects
department could actually show you on
screen
likewise the traumatizing backstory that
you can't see is always going to end up
being more interesting so between the
cat
and rick whose side are we supposed to
take here i mean
this is another one of those places
where the show presents us with two
conflicting sides
implicitly asking the question of which
one is right
and neither of them is 100 right
the answer of course lies somewhere in
the middle perhaps the best solution is
to ask questions
and be content with not always getting
all the answers
or when you do get an answer not being
dissatisfied because you asked for it so
vehemently there are some things that
demand more than surface level analysis
to fully enjoy
in fact one of the things that we love
about rick and morty is that it's one of
those shows where we get rewarded for
picking apart all the little details
however
it's easy to make the mistake of
assuming that because i have
questions the show owes me answers yes
certain things shouldn't be left open
nobody likes a gaping plot hole
but certain things invite speculation
and that's intentional
answering our questions outright would
kill all the fun of them we can trust
that they'll eventually pay off some of
the show's bigger mysteries
like what's going on with evil morty and
everything that's happening back at the
citadel
well accepting that we're not gonna find
out exactly what it was that rick and
jerry saw in that mine scanner
i don't think that this cat is coming
back i don't think that that's a
question
that's ever going to get solved which
means that from now until the end of
time we have to be content with it
just being a theory a film
theory and cuts
you